get ready for more Kardashian Jenner's  to keep up with because kylie jenner is  pregnant et has learned that kylie is  pregnant with her first child the source  tells ET she's expecting a baby girl  with boyfriend Travis Scott the source  does not know if the pregnancy was  planned or not but says the 20 year old  is happy quote Kylie always wanted to be  a young mom and she may be young but  she's very maternal what do you feel  like of course Kylie has lots of  practice we're told she is a quote  hands-on aunt with Kourtney and Kim's  kids and the source adds that kylie is  excited her baby will have cousins close  to her age too our source also tells us  that between Kylie's sisters and mom  Kris the baby will be very well cared  for and so loved  you